hello everyone and welcome to round four
of the 2020 Tata Steel masters edition
it's the georgian van forest versus
magnus carlsen and before we check out
the game I just have a very short
announcement I was a guest at Ben
Johnson's chess podcast so if you if
anybody have some extra time and are
interested in that I will put a link to
it in the description below it will be
the first thing you will see so it's my
first time ever on a podcast I'm not
saying it's good but you are more than
welcome to check it out so that being
said let's check out the game and it's a
very important game for Magnus cos and
so far he's been undefeated for 110
games which equals 70 vehicles record of
110 unbeaten games and if Carlsen
manages to survive this one it's 111
games and he sets a new world record so
will he be able to do this well we will
check it out and so far the two of them
met only once and it was in last year's
Tata Steel masters edition our van
forest test that crosses watches
championship preparation and they played
the sveshnikov sicilian but carson was
able to win that game proving that his
world championship preparation was I was
indeed well great so let's see what he
prepared for for this year
so van forest opens with E 4 we have E 5
by Magnus Knight f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to c4 and we have Knight to f6
the two Knights defense and more most
likely event for Spreaker for this as
Carson went for the two Knights defense
well quite some times throughout his
career
so Knight to g5 the Knights attack going
for the 40 f7 pawn and Carson replies
with d5 it is the the the most common
reply with eke after Sun d5 Knight to a5
challenging the Bishop Bishop to b5
check c6 and now D captures on c6 we
have B captures on c6 and now returning
nuts - nuts - e2 but the d3 if any of
you
I checked out my stream a few days ago I
played one game where I win for this
Bishop to d3 line I said and that it's a
it's popular today although I don't
really know why Bishop to d3 is played I
do know that black shouldn't go h6 like
usually
when the bishop is money - because now
you can retreat with the night and II
for you don't have to go to f3 and allow
efore but underneath that I mean you
will have to move it at some point at
the free up the the D pawn but it is
very popular today Knights the d5
opening up an attack towards the night
and now Knight back to f3 so now you do
not have supports to push efore with the
ship to d6 by Magnus in mount Knight to
c3 with castles by Magnus and now there
is one there are a few games where
castles was played but here
Ivan forest goes for Bishop to e2 right
away making room for his deep on and it
is already as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so Carson replies
with Knight to f4 attacks the blush upon
e2n demand for is just castles with
Bishop to g4 by Carson and now d3
opening up an attack towards the knight
and cousin says okay let's just grab
that to grab that Bishop we are upon
down but which is normal when you go for
the two Knights defense but I do have
the bishop pair so Knight captures with
Czech Queen captures I need to end now
f5 so already quite a quite a dangerous
expansion for black but also for white
and here when forest goes for e3 just
asking what you want to do you want to
capture or do you want to go back up to
age 5
of course Magnus is not interested in
capturing he wants to preserve his
leadership ere he goes back and now
immediately g4 and up until this point
when forest didn't spend any time so
this is all a well within his
preparation and Carlson has to decide
what to do now and here he took some
time but he fairly quickly decided on F
captures on g4 and now comes Knight to
g5 and here already black has to be very
careful of course you cannot capture as
the bishop would hang on h5 and there
are well there are some ideas you could
try like rook to f3 seems appealing but
not really because White will not
capture with an item and allow G
captures on f3
now white will just by H capture Sanji 4
and now everything hangs just the
shopkeepers and g4 and queenie for
threatening the bishop threatening the
rook and threatening to capture on h7 so
you will either have to give up the
bishop by playing some like Bishop f5
but then you give up the roof so you
cannot save everything
you're just dead lost so after Knight to
g5 Magnus goes for Queen to d7 and here
it's interesting to note that Queen sate
Queen 8 and Queen to d7 are the top two
recommendations by the engine so it is
it was kind of weird to see that when
first took some time now here to reply
so it's it seems like it's not within
his preparation but he replies with the
strongest idea Knight CTE 4 brings
another Knight closer to the black King
also a threatens to pick up the
disrepair so Magnus and moves it Bishop
to e7 and now Knight to g3 goes after
the light square Bishop Magnus moves
that as well and now what do you play
here well the well the most interesting
thing to consider is definitely Queen
captures on e5 if you can grab another
pawn why not and it can be played
however it it runs into a really
complicated position for example G
captures on h3 and now it's hard to say
what's happening here
there is the the interesting Queen
captures on a5 line of course all you
see that the knight is hanging but it's
not good so it's just a just a very
complex position which obviously event
for us did not prepare but if you
capture here then you get h6 threatening
to win win back the piece the knight
moves and now you go Queen to g4 with
ideas of Queen f3 Quincy to mate and the
only way for white to defend this is
king h2 Queen f3 now King captures an h3
and now rook f5 threatening the Queen
and shift the rook to h5 with mate
because the knight is the knight is
pinned you will not be able to move it
but White has Knights to d2 going after
the Queen so here we would see just the
Queen captures and g3 winning back the
piece King captures and rook captures an
a5 and the game continues Magnus is down
down upon but he still has the bishop
pair so as usual a trade off so this is
what could happen this Queen captures an
e5 move however even forest goes for the
immediate Queen captures in g4 which
means he's still well within his
prepared line Queen captures and g4 and
now H captures and g4 and now comes c5
by Magnus freeing the c6 square
his night he wants to remember the night
to d4 or b4 depending on what white
place and there was some saying in the
chat that Magnus offered the draw here
as when forests took a lot of time to
respond to this move some maybe 11 12
minutes however later it was said that a
Magnus did not in fact offer a draw here
so there's that
so night back to e4 by then forest now
preparing Bishop to e3 to go after the
c5 pawn and Magnus goes Knight to c6 now
ready to remover it the d4 or b4 with
Bishop to e3 with a double attack on the
pawn here and now Knight the d4 Bishop
to b4 is also very interesting as you go
after the CT pawn but then you get rook
F c1 rook 8 the c8 now defending here
and if you if you kick away the night
then you can just go Knight back to the
5 and the pawn is nicely protected so
this is one way to go about it Magnus
decides on a different idea Knight to d4
and already here Magnus was up on time
so then forest is no longer within his
preparation he's down to one hour and
crossing his 1 hour and 15 minutes on
the clock and here the c2 point is under
attack and again evan forest spends
about 10 minutes on his move he goes
look 8 2 c1 just defends the pawn if c3
if c3 you just go back nice to e6 and
then you're stuck with the better which
the backwards d3 pawn is gonna be very
weak it will be easy to attack it so not
to the greatest of moves so rook 8 2 c1
defending and now rook 8 the c8 by
Magnus procuring C for Magnus also wants
to get rid of the weak isolated pawn and
here King to g2 by Van forest and the
Magnus immediately strikes with c4 so we
had Bishop captures on d4 and then
Forest gives up in the other bishop as
well we have a capture Sunday before and
now f3 strengthening the night here and
now rook the c6 Magnus prepares to bring
the other look into the game as well and
now
b3 this was the the critical line and it
it invites Bishop to e3 but the position
is extremely complicated here Magnus
played it fairly quickly here at the
moment
III was played when forest was already
down to 35 minutes Magnus still had over
an hour so Magnus quickly played Bishop
to a 3 and here now I did I catch some
footage a live footage where event
forest was considering this position and
he was really struggling he was
struggling what whether or not should he
play D captures on c4 and this is the
critical decision to make here
he did not play it it's a hard decision
to make Bishop captures rook captures
and now you have these three 3 points
here against one well ok 4 but this one
it is guarded by this pawn so basically
3 2 1 and well you are up against Magnus
so definitely not an easy decision to
make but this was the way to go to seek
for advantage now he decides to move the
rook he plays rook Sita II won and now
Magnus captures rook capture son d3 we
have seek after Sunday 3 and now a5 he
wants the bush a4 at some point a trade
of that bone as well we have looked the
f2 by van forest now guarding the second
rank but now Bishop the c1 again
immediately played by Magnus and here
when forest is already down to 25
minutes on the clock
the idea is to bring the bishop over to
e3 and the bishop pair will do do the
Deuter best well harass the rooks and
maybe even pick one of them off we have
Knights to d2 and here the ship captures
on d3 grabbing a pawn with Knight to c4
here when forced once Bishop captures
and c4 followed by rook captures here
now you have to move the bishop to d5 to
keep an eye on the rook and then after
characters captures we get to this
pretty much equal endgame it's not equal
white is better as well blacks black has
three point islands of white has two but
on the other hand and Magnus has a past
deep on so it's hard to decide
from this position if it will be a
strength or a weakness but the with the
black King being so far away it's hard
to say that it's you know you will be
able to just just push it or something
like that now but okay after Knight to
c4 Magnus goes for Bishop to F for
instead and now comes Knight to e5
attacking the rookin c6 and Magnus goes
look the c3 as the bishop on d3 is under
attack as well so rook the rook to c3
and when forest picks off one of the
bishops so Knight captures and III route
characters on d3 and now Knight to f5
and here again a very interesting moment
a magnus plays g6 pushing back the night
and here he's asking do you wanna
capture on d4 or not it's hard to decide
for example if Knight captures on d4
sorry nothin not on d4 first of course
when forest played rook to e4
he kicked away the bishop and added a
second attacker here Magnuson removed
the Bishop Bishop g5 and now he has to
decide whether to capture on d4 I
overlooked the roof to e4 but he doesn't
he plays Knight to e7 checkpoint being
that after Knight captures here you have
to calculate Bishop to e3 with a double
attack but then you have Knights to e6
going after the rook Bishop captures
Knight captures on f8 and now Magnus has
rook to d2 with some nasty discoveries
but that's the thing there there are no
nasty discoveries here so once the
knight moves you're gonna pick up a da
to pawn and still everything is on the
light square there's really nothing to
worry about there are no no tricks here
but still when forest decides for night
to the e7 check instead and here came to
h8 and now even forces down to 11
minutes Magnus has some 55 minutes on
the clock with Knight back to c6
again threatening to pick up the d4 pawn
and now Bishop to e3 by Magnus there was
the possibility of Bishop to h4 a very
interesting idea if you if you move the
rook away from the defense of the f3
pond and the other rope crashes through
so you have to go Knights the e5 defend
and attack once the rook moves rook the
one now you go rook to f1 again offer a
trade rug d to check engage three attack
the bishop and Russia back to d8 so here
are basically keeping the tension
however Magnus decided to go for Bishop
to e3 instead defending and attacking
and now rook the e2 and we'd work to e
to move for T has been played and
players have reached time control so
when forest against some precious
additional time
we've looked at d1 by Magnus now
preparing rook to g1 to push back the
kingdom she wants to go rook the c1 and
start pushing his passport when first
takes this opportunity to grab the a
5-point with Knight captures on a5 and
now when forest has two connected
passports on the Queen side but Carlson
has a very very strong past deep on so
here Magnus goes look the g1 check we
have King to h2 and to not look back to
c1 not allowing the Knights to enter the
game also preparing to capture on f3 and
also preparing to push his past deep on
so here Ivan first really took some time
to consider what to do here and in the
end he plays King back to g2 it defends
the f3 pawn and also the King is much
closer to the past D pawn sorry yes the
past D pawn
so rook the g1 check again by Magnus
checking to see if maybe even forest is
interested in playing something else
although nothing else is is is good
soaking back to h2 rook the c1 and here
we have King to g2 and now what do you
think Carson played next did he repeat
and accepted a draw by threefold
repetition and claimed his 111 games
without a single loss so claiming the
world record or did he continue the game
by pushing d3 so what do you think
happened here well I'll tell you what
happened here Magnus played rook to g1
check and well no it was actually in
this position after King to g2 was
played that the players agreed to a draw
you could decide to push the D pawn but
it's not not really promising anything
you do win the exchange however you have
to give give up one more point because
after this rook captures on e3 you're
gonna play D - threatening d1 and then
it goes rook d4 you're gonna bring the
Queen into the game captures captures
and now you have to play this position
where yes you robbed the exchange but
when forest has two connected pass
points on the Queen side so probably
there's a very special way how to treat
this position which I'm sure Carlsen
knows but he decided that that it wasn't
worth it and that if this was
then Magnus would have gone for it I
believe but he decided it wasn't and
after King to g2 they agreed to a draw
and Magnus is now 111 games classical
games without a single loss the last
game he lost was in 2018 - Chartier mama
D are off in the bill chess festival and
after that no losses so which is quite
impressive as I've read that on average
his his opponents were rated 2700
something whereas a circuit TV pubs
record his opponents were rated in
average 2,400 something so quite quite
the record so yeah another day another
record as the title says I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank jose
aldo ali Yunior frank combs proctor
mining and a victor of ice for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos here
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the Tata
Steel the coverage of the Women's World
Chess Championship checking up any
wonderful suggestions and so on and do
check out the podcast at Ben Jonson the
links are in the description below so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day